I wonder who's gonna get picked to host
the Oscars now did they ask somebody yet
or no did someone get it I don't know
yeah I don't know I think I my opinion
is is that you two should host it oh my
god imagine there was no Ansel it why in
the folk model we would go to rehearsal
yeah
the producers being the audience and
they've got caught I know you guys were
rehearsing we're gonna get somebody new
yeah but there's no way oh they kept
doing with it's not only that though
it's like but it's also this so is that
public Chris will be able to do it and
I'm not downgrading you know where I'm
at in my career but I think most people
will be like why him daliyah yeah he's
you know delete it no listen it's a
campaign let's start it it's not just
that it's just that you have to know
where you're at and I'm not downplaying
my game
maybe if you did some press before
handing my bill to do the you know I
don't think being fifth lead on a an
asset calm yeah yeah man but also I was
thinking about this and it doesn't
really it doesn't help your career
Oh seeing the Oscars no it doesn't it
really doesn't I mean if you're Kevin
Hart you're Kevin Hart he's big anyway
it doesn't matter if the rock does it
who [ __ ] cares he's biggest [ __ ] yeah
those people or people that are like
doing it because they already like Billy
Crystal in a more you know but like if
you were I mean like like
what's-her-name from Princess Diaries
did it right and then like what it got
weird is weird
he got he was he got like a lot of flack
for that and she did as well yeah they
got a boner were like yeah you know and
then and then it felt like they felt
like they weren't well I don't about
James Franco but it felt like she wasn't
as big of a star after that yeah I don't
know maybe more unlikable after that for
sure it's like heard I was supposed to
go to the Asian Excellence Awards uh-huh
and we didn't go because we want to hurt
yourself because I was sick his tailbone
that's all just sudden he had flu
symptoms
I fell on my tailbone when we're looking
at a house and we didn't show up to the
Asian Excellence in words but in many
ways okay not showing up is cool I think
not doing RSVP if you put it in RSVP and
you don't show up that's not cool I know
that's not cool and I apologize for that
but I also there is a there is a part of
me that when I get invited in things and
I don't show up I think that all that
also I feel like that that's it's okay
mm-hmm that doesn't necessarily hurt me
oh because in my mind I'm like the
reason why I wanted to go is because
Steven you and Jimmy Oh yang everyone's
gonna be there because it's an Asian
thing right and I think a part of me is
like yeah I'm not doing that
why because I in my head I'm thinking if
I should go because maybe I'll get a
movie yeah but then when I go I don't
get a movie like I hosted that thing
twice and nothing happened oh you did
yeah nothing happened
like I in fact it gave me no work he was
work I lost work because I did that
because when I used to host that thing
and all the executives and everyone was
there and I was funny and then it was
years of no auditions at all yeah you're
a big like that's why that happened
because I did that and then and now
that's why it's like this you you're
that you're like that could not have
anyone here you'll be like I [ __ ] I
shook the guy's hand wrong that's it
yeah and I didn't get the action movie
yeah that's you
[Music]